[Musique]
dans quelques jours les deux conseils
départementaux alsacien fusionneront
pour former la collectivité européenne
d'alsace à colmar
si pour l'instant l'hémicycle évident on
s'y prépare à accueillir l'acte
fondateur de la nouvelle collectivité le
2 janvier terme d'un parcours
institutionnelles engagées il ya presque
cinq ans un peu comme les enfants on
arrive à la fête de noël pour nous noël
c'est le 2 janvier on arrivera à cette
nouvelle collectivité européenne que
nous avons conçu réfléchi travaillé
depuis trois ans le chemin parcouru
depuis cinq ans je suis particulièrement
fier de ce qui a été fait dans notre
département du haut-rhin et je pense que
mon collègue bas rhinois l'est tout
autant pour la partie bas rhinoise alors
que l'alsace institutionnels
disparaissait avec la création de la
région grand test dès 2016 les élus
locaux se mobilisent pour lui redonner
une réalité politique l'élection d'
emmanuel macron en 2017 fait bouger les
lignes
toute sortie du grand est est exclue
mais une nouvelle collectivité aux
compétences détendu pourra être créée le
29 octobre 2018 l'accord de matignon
pose les bases du projet qui sera
ensuite voté par l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat
si le 1er janvier 2021 date de création
officielle de la cia constitue
l'aboutissement d'un long parcours pour
les élus ce n'est que le début d'une
nouvelle aventure
c'est le début de tout c'est à dire que
on s'est mis en condition d'agir
il va falloir qu'on soit à la hauteur
des attentes des alsaciens mieux les
servir mieux servir la dynamique de
chaque bassin de vie m l'alsace au
premier plan là elle revient au premier
plan institutionnel il faut qu'elle
revienne au premier plan du
développement économique de l'emploi il
faut qu'elle soit reconnue nationalement
et internationalement donc on a beaucoup
d'enjeu a relevé il faudra qu'on soit au
niveau des attentes des habitants c'est
ça notre priorité
alors qu'est ce qui va changer
concrètement pour les alsaciens au 1er
janvier dans la vie quotidienne
assez peu de choses en fait les services
rendus à la population resteront les
mêmes
si les conseils départementaux
fusionnent au niveau administratif et
politique
les deux départements continueront
d'exister en tant que circonscription
administrative de l'état en ce début
2000 21 c'est surtout le retour du nom
alsace qui va se faire remarquer
c'est le retour de l'alsace sur le plan
institutionnel
on reparlera alsace l'alsace figure à
nouveau dans les livres d'histoire et
sûre sur les pancartes de notre de notre
territoire ce qui n'était plus le cas
depuis quelques années donc je crois que
le retour à l'alsace c'est sans doute ce
qui changera politiquement
psychologiquement pour les habitants par
contre dans la vie du quotidien bien au
contraire ça devrait pouvoir continuer
en ce qui concerne vraiment la qualité
le service de proximité pour pleinement
mesurer les effets de la nouvelle
collectivité dans la vie des alsaciens
il faudra attendre encore quelque temps
la cia reprendra les compétences des
départements actuels dont les politiques
vont progressivement convergé sur tout
un ensemble de nouvelles compétences
venue de l'état et de la région seront à
sa disposition pour intervenir dans de
nombreux domaines mais là encore il
faudra être patient pour mesurer
l'impact de la méthode alsacienne ce qui
attendrait des miracles tout de suite je
vais tout de suite pour dire que s'il
n'y a pas de miracle un jeune homme on
ne fait pas évoluer les choses en un
claquement de doigts c'est un travail de
longue haleine alors l'alsace retrouve
des capacités à agir renforcer sur
internet un certain nombre de sujets sur
le bilinguisme sur le transfrontalier
sur les mobilités routière donc on va
pouvoir être en capacité d'organiser les
choses de manière plus plus simple plus
efficace
mais au-delà de ça pour moi s'ils
voulaient ce qui est important c'est le
service public qu'on va rendre aux
alsaciens
c'est comment dans leur vie quotidienne
on va à pouvoir améliorer le service aux
plus fragiles l'épanouissement de toutes
les générations
c'est ça qui va falloir relever en
s'appuyant déjà sur ce qu'on fait de
bien dans le haut rhin dans le bas rhin
va tirer meilleur parti de ce qu'il fout
qui fonctionnait bien dans le rhône ce
qui fonctionnait bien dans le bain pour
que ça profite à tous les alsaciens les
collectivités européennes d'alsace aura
de nombreux défis à relever dès sa
création notamment les crises sanitaires
et économiques à plus long terme pour le
président du conseil départemental du
bas-rhin
c'est la crise démocratique à laquelle
devra apporter des réponses
il faut montrer aux habitants dans une
démarche de démocratie contributive
active qu'on peut que la démocratie ait
du sens que en travaillant en proximité
avec les habitants en proximité avec les
territoires
on peut construire une action publique
du sens et qui est intelligible pour les
habitants et si on réussit cela on aura
relevé une partie du défi c'est à dire
que on me permettra la confiance dans
notre société
et ça c'est fondamental dans un contexte
aujourd'hui de le traumatisme et des
fragilités que l'on traverse
pour le président du conseil
départemental du haut rhin la cea
pourrait bien montrer le chemin vers une
nouvelle étape de décentralisation
je crois qu'elle peut elle peut jouer
réellement le laboratoire national d'une
collectivité nouvelle d'une collectivité
moderne d'une collectivité qui sait
aller de l'avant je pense que c'est
qu'une étape
peut-être peut-être je l'espère je le
souhaite qu'elle pourrait avoir d'autres
compétences et que peut-être un jour
elle retrouvera sa capacité régionale
rendez-vous le 2 janvier pour l'acte
fondateur de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace puis au mois de juin pour la
première élection du futur conseiller
d'alsace